essence bus drivers are always on the
road going from one end of the city to
the other they all work for the city on
transport services company evac lately
rumors about cuts have been circulating
a dampener on their mood thing of my
future we always hear a lot about what's
planned and then nothing happens we're
waiting for the day things actually
change its weapons with others the local
authority has made cutbacks and its
public service companies like evac that
have to suffer the consequences they've
already had to layoff 700 people over
the past few years and freeze vital
investments all while passenger numbers
are actually on the rise Alice Boston
financia hbu home distressin everything
that's limiting the city's budget
including the rwe dividend will
automatically affect us that's whether
it'll involve concrete measures we can't
say yet first its essence totally nice
it was mr. bisson Don the city's debt
stacks up to more than 3 billion euros
as energy giant rwe has decided against
paying a dividend this year another 18
million euros are gone treasurers had
budgeted for at least half of that my
sins the link doesn't rd marulan in what
this house usually we managed to make up
for such budget deficits as we go along
um you have these my I need it but this
time I have my doubts because funding
refugee accommodation has already
stretched our fun when the fifties on
tumbling on Shawn unscrew and Parvati
incredible eater
essen has to take on eight thousand
refugees this year alone that's further
straining the city's Treasury which is
already stretched an unemployment rate
of twelve percent means that welfare
spending is high rwe expressed this
understanding of the city's predicament
but the board is firm in its decision to
not pay a dividend this year local
authority representatives had agreed
after all rwe has slipped into the red
is this kindness mustard it's not that
we don't want to it's not good or can
for that matter if you don't make money
you can't pay anything when we made a
lot of money we paid a lot to our
shareholders you need to acknowledge
that we face in hard times I'm afraid
shareholders also survived objects in
the oven mitt evac employees are now
hoping they won't have to bear the brunt
now that another source of income for
the city has run dry